the big advantage that completing Square
has over factorization is plainly
sometimes you just can't factorize right
like how long are you going to sit there
trying to guess like thirds and stuff
like that it's not going to happen
so completing the square just gets those
out effortlessly which is really nice
there's one other thing I showed you how
to do to remember it had to do how to do
with this guy what can we do with this
how is completing the square relevant to
them you can find the center you can
find the radius when it's some expanded
mess of terms if you complete the square
you can get it back dries and off you go
okay so we look at two more things that
you can do with completing the square
first
the formula now we know the formula
right the formula for solely a quadratic
equation is x equals minus B plus or
minus da da da da and it comes from
completing the square okay now it
wouldn't be very likely that you'd be
actually asked to derive the quadratic
formula however what would be likely is
you're asked to use all the same skills
they're deriving it would so let's
quickly revive this because we've seen
this before we have right so I need you
to help me have a look non Monaco drat
ik so the first thing I need to do to
use this technique is divided by a to
turn into a monic quadratic that gives
us this okay is this ringing bells I can
now take what sorry I can now take this
guy I don't need him do I and he's going
to go over the right-hand side because
what I'm really interested in is making
the square out of this guy like so okay
at this point is where I do the
completion of the square what am I going
to add on
you're looking at which number which
number Vionnet and you do two things to
it you 5 and square
hi 1 square okay so when I have it I get
beyond 2a and then when you square that
you're onto a you get B squared on for
each word okay so I've successfully
completed the square which means I
should make sure I do this on both sides
like so now I can actually factorize
this left-hand thing so what are the
factors remember you have been squared
to get this but to get this you just
just do the having part right so this is
B on C you a that should look familiar
right that looks mu as we go through
like oh I recognize these structures
like for example over here you've got
two fractions I'd prefer to welcome as
one so what will I do what we're gonna
do with this guy I'll multiply by for a
on for a oh yeah that's right that looks
familiar doesn't it right plus B squared
okay so far so good
what squared oh thank you yep I did
complete the square after all okay um
now what we're going to do III I don't
want this squared thing I want the X on
its own so I will take the square root
of both sides I know when I do that that
that introduces a pair of solutions
right it's not just the square root of
this thing b squared minus 4ac on 4a
squared it's not just that's where it's
also the negative version of that yes
looking good we're almost there we're
not far I'm going to get rid of this guy
so what I do I will subtract
while I'm at it I see I can do some work
he because what 4a squared is itself a
perfect square so I can take the square
root of that that gives me this and from
now on your memory should sort of take
over right the next line is the
quadratic formula okay
now I'm not going to write it because
you know it well enough and also because
this form of writing it actually
highlights a useful feature that I want
to talk about this guy what is that it's
not quite the on its own first we get
the axis of symmetry from which we can
find the vertex right why is it that
this is the axis of symmetry what makes
this the axis of symmetry excuse me when
you use the quadratic formula and it
gives you two numbers at the end like
say 1 and 5 what are those numbers what
do they mean what are 1 & 5
they are the it is the zeros right the
roots
well the axis of symmetry is directly
halfway between wherever your route are
yeah so that's why it's like from your
axis you go to the right a little bit
and then you go to the left a little bit
and that will give you your roots set
that again oh yes yeah we will come to
that I promise ok we'll come back this
point so number 1 that's where I get
that problem you're going to be using
that copiously today there's one other
thing and it's what Jake was mentioning
before which is about not solving
equations but finding the vertex
so when you draw a quadratic function
what shape you get when you hear a
quadratic you get a parabola right so
the vertex is an important feature of
that parabola now looking at what's on
the board how could you use what on the
board to find the vertex what would you
do
yep you take this number right and then
you'd set it back into whatever your
thing was and then you'll get a y-value
okay but completing the square can get
you there directly rather than go into
the formula and then do this other thing
watch let's consider something like this
I'm going to do a thing like this okay
now excuse me the reason I'm
highlighting this K is because there's
an important feature about it that will
become clear as soon as we start to go
through okay how do I find the vertex of
this I can and distance two totally fine
I can find the axis of symmetry take
that x value and pop it back inside but
completing the square can do that for us
on its own just like for this guy it can
find cycles don't have a vertex what do
I have the center it's exactly the same
process watched to complete the square
here I needed to make things Manik do I
need to do that looks okay right now so
I've given you nice easy numbers okay
what did I do here how did this guy get
over here or more importantly why did it
get over there yeah I don't need that
constant around the completion of the
square totally depends on this guy does
that make sense so for this question
what's the part that's important a very
good x squared plus 5x is where the
business is going to happen so therefore
I'm just going to isolate that and get
the nine out of the way like so happy
with that now let's complete the square
you know Y minus nine over here here's
the number where all the action is so
I'm going to have and square when you do
that
having it gives you two and a half
squaring two and a half gives you six
and a quarter of course your calculator
can confirm that for you if you like
you added to the right which means which
means you should add it to the left like
so everything's all balanced and now I
can factorize right let's tidy this guy
up six and a quarter minus nine is two
and three quarters like so the
right-hand side is now a square because
I completed it okay what's it the square
of okay now remember back when we were
talking about real functions and I said
if you have some kind of function like
this and you know exactly what it looks
like then you should be able to tell me
what this is right
what's going to be the difference
between these two it's been shifted
translators which way has it translated
to the left very good two and a half
units okay
well that's what's happened here isn't
it if you knew what x squared looks like
well this is like x squared but shifted
to the left two and a half units so if
you just take a regular parabola where's
the vertex
it's a zero zero but this one has been
shifted two and a half units to the left
so where is it now
it's two and a half to the left isn't it
and accordingly what's happened
vertically where's this gone it's gone
up two and three points okay does that
make sense you I've done this what's
nice about this is you can find the
vertex without ever having to like solve
this thing you can't solve if there are
no real roots okay because as you can
see this is too far above the axis it'll
actually never come back okay